Welcome to the
Ministry of Defense for a visit
British Secretary of Defense Ben
Wallace will have an interview The two
ministers will make a statement and
then there will be an opportunity to
ask questions Mr Minister, thank you very much
hello once again you Ben I'm glad to
have you here in Berlin first times
looking for the to my with possible
and we had very constructive
talks today ladies and gentlemen which
were prepared and which had a full
agenda and we agree and
as Defense Secretary I am
aware of how the UK is
a strong partner for us  In
many fields, of course, this begins
with the support of the Ukraine, we
are moving forward together, both in terms of
multiple rocket launchers and
battle tanks, we as Germans are
particularly aware of
air defense and we find
that Great Britain and Germany
are the biggest supporters after the USA
and that is true  just for material for
training maintenance repair short
that is a real turning point in which
we live
but also in other fields
we work together excellently the
evacuation from the Sudan was overall
successful a successful operation
also because the French,
British, Americans and Germans in
particular, along with a few others  The British armed forces have
worked together so successfully and well,
about 25 Germans, we brought out
about 15 British nationals and
I would
like to take this opportunity to thank you for the good cooperation
there and we
also congratulate you, dear Ben, on your
great achievement 2400 British
nationals  Getting everyone out of the country
was
definitely a logistical challenge.
The evacuation from Sudan has
also confirmed the resilience and
reliability of the trust in our
partnership and
in a crisis situation that is all the more
remarkable. We are very happy that everything went
so smoothly  worked out until
the handing over of the management of the airport from
the Bundeswehr
to you from the German Air Force.
The German-British cooperation
naturally has even more facets, for
example the German-British
Pioneer Bridge Battalion 130 from Minden,
which King Charles recently
visited here  but our
comba that has just expired is also an air
policing in the Baltic States is a
success story
and here too we are pulling together at
the exposed point in NATO's
eastern flank we will interlock even more closely
than the nations of a serious
presence Germany Great Britain and
Canada  on the one hand Lithuania is
Estonia and
Latvia on the other hand we have
established the 3 + 3 format at my invitation.
I will invite you to do so again on the
sidelines of the next meeting in Brussels
because we believe that it is precisely
the three states that
bear special responsibility there  should also coordinate closely with our three
Baltic partners
when it
comes to better exercises, training
logistics and that is why it will also be a matter of
holding the next commando meeting in
Lithuania in May,
but also British participation in
European Sky at the European skull
Shield Initiative is worth mentioning again
I am very grateful that
it is an important signal for
joint cooperation and for all of this
we need further support Ukraine contributions in the alliance strengthening Bundeswehr and that is the common
that is the next common point
more cash more  capabilities more
contributions and that means that two
percent target in the budget remains a
common there is therefore less to the
question of how it
is to be defined and much more to the fact
that the skills must be
able to be updated over a decade
overall a very  fruitful
conversation I look forward to
continuing and got to know Ben Wallace in the
first meetings in my short term of office
as someone with whom you
can cultivate a close and direct exchange that is director
without naming names than with
my other and clearer but  also more
friendly and therefore free from
misunderstandings, which I am very happy to
remain the light chamber of the
ministerial John may job for yes
have been here tree changing
this the system
he got you too fast now we have to
make sure that the microphone is there in time
Mr. Müller  would be the next one
we'll wait a moment until this micro is with him
Mühle at the next
yes many thanks Holger Mühle Bonner
general ad a question to Minister
Ben Wallace there are reports that your
country should work together with the Netherlands on
a fighter jet coalition
what can your country do  in delivering fighter jets to the
Ukraine you have already
made a decision and which states
are involved and a question for
Minister Pistorius in this
context what could contribute in
Germany to this fighter jet
coalition and will it
contribute something thanks
from the potent night of the whole
deliver  and
here crime support
also on the point that i have said several times
in the past when it comes to the
question of the quality and
quantity of support from Germany for Ukraine
that is above all about
delivering things that can be used immediately
or can be used in a very short time
is above all about
delivering what is most urgently needed
and at the same time what is delivered
where sustainability
is given, both in terms of logistics and
maintenance and repair because that is
what ultimately matters that is of no use to us
and also the  Ukraine nothing if
we deliver things that
are no longer usable after three months because of a lack of material
repair skills or
capacities or those who
operate the vehicles that is why we stick
to the skills that we have
we have always said we are the
experts for tanks and for
air defense in this  area
we are leading in support of
Ukraine and that remains so we are
concentrating on the
air defense of the u Sabine could we are
concentrating on the supply of
additional ammunition we are concentrating
on the repair of the tanks that
we have supplied along with others
that will be in  Poland is passing, so that's
our focus, that's our
expertise, we don't have any F16
fighter jets, as you know, and neither the
Tornado nor the Eurofighter are suitable for
helping now, especially since training and
many other things - that's just what I
said - are far too expensive for
Ukraine  would be able to help at short notice
further questions Stefan
would have to be secretary did
I understand you correctly and the
fighter jet coalition really only consists
of offering the Ukrainians the best possible
training? I
actually understood your government to mean
that you would look for other
nations that could make App 16 available
Could you be a bit more detailed
and he, the Chancellor's defense minister,
said today that there were no
requirements for Germany
to take part in the possible fighter jet coalition,
so I did
n't really understand President Selenski during his visit
and would you
rule out the possibility that we would ever be involved in this conflict
will see German tornadoes or Eurofighters in the Ukraine
thank you very much I'll start with the
basic remark that has helped me
a lot throughout my political life
I'm not a supporter who
is exclusive I can't
rule out
answering a question today
that in  three years
could be different than it is today that depends
on the circumstances of course of course
at the moment as I said we don't see this
situation at all in the
position hasn't changed
and we can't play an active role
in such an alliance in a
play such a coalition because we have neither
the training
capacities nor the aircraft and
in the end it depends as far as I know anyway on
the White House namely to decide that
the F16 combat aircraft
may be delivered at all can be trained
from on these aircraft these are all
not questions that are in  Berlin will decide
the next one,
add one more briefly as a model for
the procedure we are talking about.
If I spoke earlier about
the repair work for the
Leopard tanks in Poland, then this is an
operative project between
Germany and the Polish armaments industry
and the two ministries involved,
but the whole thing costs 150 million euros
per year to operate, so we
went there and said at the last
meeting in Ramstein that we would
organize it, but
in the end the financing has to come from everyone via
the IFP or whatever, so to
speak  a pound racing system for
such a system that can also be a model
for this approach or for
other projects and areas
I heard we still have three
minutes and that would be the
last question for you in the front right from us
looks like world television one  Question to
you Minister Wallace if you now say
you want to train and help the states to
deliver the fighter jets where is
the fighter jet alliance that was spoken of
this morning also with the delivery
of F16 fighter jets and Minister Pistorius
when it came to the main battle tanks
Germany insisted that  the
Americans are helping to deliver the unsuitable
abrames tanks they
just said they want to focus on their
defense capabilities from airspace and
the tanks would they
stand in the way when it comes to
forming a combat tank fighter alliance to
not participate because it doesn't  the
competence is
I'll start if I may I'll start
it's not about whether we do
n't participate in something, we just can't actively
make a contribution when it
comes to financing issues, so to
a certain extent we are just as involved in the question
as everyone else, only we are
active  not to contribute we do
n't have training skills we do
n't have the appropriate aircraft
so the debate doesn't arise for us
as in our position that
explains the reference to the
core skills we have firstly
again I would disagree with the hypothesis
that the earth
be unsuitable for us and am  In the end it was
all about coordinated action
and that's exactly what's happening here from the
British and Dutch side.
They also point out that it's
only possible in concert, only coordinated
and that the right approach
was only if we act as a unit,
we can also act as a unit
Develop an effect for the benefit
there is still no okay until then there
is the initiative we want to actively
support the Ukraine on this issue
Germany cannot take on this active part because we do
not have the capacity or the skills
[music]
I would like to add one more sentence
connect because it is important to me again
President Selenski did not
come to Berlin and demanded
we need fighter jets in large numbers
came to Berlin to receive a package
of 2.7 billion euros from German
support as such a support
support package
and to accept it  to say thank you and to
point out which systems and which
military issues are in the
foreground and he also
left no doubt about that it is
air sovereignty and that is in particular the
air the ground-based air
defense these are the priorities
right now and the preparation of the
Ukrainian  Offensive whatever it
takes for that a fighter jet will
play a role in one way or another but certainly not much for that
and by Germany and
possibly by the UK in
terms of a political down ship
but we should still
make it very clear what really is  for
the security of Ukraine is in the
foreground and that is the tanks
was for that is the fencing
fighting in combined combat
it is the ammunition and that is
the airport defense
then the time is up thank you very much for
your questions thank you very much for your
answers  and have a nice day everyone